hey guys i just wanted to take a second
thank you all we just cracked the
hundred thousand subscriber thing on
youtube and everyone tells me that's a
big milestone number we've been doing
this for about two and a half years to
get to the hundred thousand but we've
gotten almost 20,000 in the last like
three months and to be a hundred percent
honest with you it's only in the last
say five weeks since we started adoro
that I really figured out what I really
want to be doing and I think we're
clearly on it now and I know what I'm
talking about and I know what I'm saying
you know in a new way and an important
way and I think that's why we're getting
the response that we're getting so I
want to thank you for that and as a
little give back to you guys I'm like
the giving tree over here I just posted
on twitter if you guys had any questions
for me so I'm just cuz I got a zillion
responses but i'm just going to plow
through a couple of them real quick so i
lost my fake place here hold on one
second okay here we go Paulie Paulie s
is there a danger in the ongoing fight
against the regressive left that can
lead to complacency and standing up
against the right I think this is a
really really great question and a lot
of people have asked me this on a bunch
of different forums that eventually if
we keep fighting against this regressive
left if somehow either we would end up
in bed with the right or we'd start
letting the right get away with things
that we won't let the left get away I
suppose there is a risk in that but at
the moment we gotta keep we gotta fight
the good fight on our side as I've said
before the right the t-ball ready
dragged the right off the deep end and
now we have to keep the left in check
before the regressives do that so I do
think it's there's a risk there but I
don't think we're at that point when we
could be worrying about that just yet
ABNA sex bow or something to that effect
said of cultural libertarians want to
form a political party do you think they
should run is Republican or Democrat I
mean I hate both parties I think they're
both pretty awful and they're both sold
out to the same people I'd say this
could actually be a chance cultural
libertarians we take from both sides we
take from both sides equally because we
have a certain set of principles that
were standing up or that don't line up
with either party anymore so I think
this could be a viable third party haha
if that was ever a possibility you know
uh Pascal the row said is there a reason
behind the four
that where you show certain clips before
releasing the full video I got a lot of
guys have asked me this also you know
partly we do it because on digital
places people like short form stuff so
we have to put out a bunch of clips
quick and then we get to the full ones
because it's very rare that people watch
you know 50 or 60 minute interview
although you guys are doing it I like
that because that's what I prefer to do
so that's part of it just because that's
the way people ingest these things the
other part is that if we put out a
couple videos one hundred percent
honestly the we get more ad revenue
that's just it i'm not paid by the ad
revenue specifically but that is sort of
how the game works it just is so that
being said as i said in the original
rules when we started this thing we're
not doing click bait we're not we're not
trying to trick you guys into watching
so that that's why we're doing that
let's see Tom Flanagan wasn't if the
left and right are still relevant labels
you know as I said before I I hate
labels I hate this Democrat versus
Republican thing here we're going to
turn around and go this way now watch
this okay look at this holy cow okay so
I hate these labels I hate talking about
these things because I think don't you
the best majority of us want basically
the same stuff and you know we live in
this cable news manufactured outrage
thing to get everybody angry at each
other instead of talking about things so
I'm trying to get past that with the
show and I think that's what you guys
are digging about it um let's see I
can't see uh-oh constructive disk or
this is from Jared Jane's constructive
discourse is rare in our culture you're
fighting good fight but this should be
but should this be something education
is tackling yes a hundred percent
education we have that that's why this
thing about safe spaces and trigger
warnings and all this crap acknowledges
is so crazy we need education you have
to hear other voices and voices that you
don't like and as well as the ones you
agree with so that you can figure out
what you believe find the truth but if
you hide half the information and you
and you immediately toss people that you
disagree without as bigots and racists
and all of that nonsense then yeah we're
never going to we're never going to be
forward as
society all right just a couple quick
more abandoned pocket don't have any
questions but want to say I'm glad I
check out your channel you're very
well-adjusted and smart alright I
thought that was question but I'll take
it are there william gray young are
there any other main topics in the
future you'd like to discuss more than
the authoritarian left yes for sure you
know this is i didn't really talk about
this much until the last six weeks and
it's funny because by me talking about
it clearly you guys have wanted to talk
about it too so I'm doing what I just
think is important to me and it's nice
and it's validating that that you guys
feel that way too but yeah as you know
sam Harris said in our interview that
when he talks about a lot of this stuff
it's at such an opportunity cost he'd
rather talk about philosophy and and
spirituality and things like that and
for me yeah I'd love to talk more about
science I really do love politics you
know just the nitty-gritty of politics
which is why an election year is
exciting for me but I want to talk with
philosophers and scientists and I wanted
to just talk about the human experience
and hopefully we can move past some of
this stuff i'll just do two more michael
higgins why the multiple network changes
so I was on tyt as you guys know and
then I was on riot for a couple months
and now ora basically a riot made me a
really nice offer from tyt and I did
explain to you guys in the same
interview that I was kind of I was kind
of over the politics anyway and then at
riot basically or it made me a really
good offer to and they wanted to do more
of the political stuff and right which
is a fantastic company doing some really
great stuff and I hopefully will partner
with them with some other things the
future they're doing more like digital
journalism out in the field not as much
studio stuff so it was just a better it
was just a better fit um and all right
one more soon i 0 NE ambitious endgame
goals maybe that's a great question I
don't know I feel like I've been doing
this forever I did 14 years of stand-up
in New Yorker siriusxm show for a while
tyt riot here we are honestly I just
want to keep having good discussion to
keep having good discussions let's see
where this happened I think we can get
long form back I think we can get
tolerance back we're doing it we're
doing it right now and I think we're
just going to keep doing it so that's
not really an end game as much as as the
journey but stick with me people who are
going to keep doing